to rock in his head tough way to start
[Music]
was a short first of all it's so crazy
to look back at ten years ago how the
iPhone X no I don't think the X is
exactly ten years old almost ten years
more than ten years ago
super fun to see that clip from ten
years ago a little baby fat there anyway
just jumped in you know kind of building
off of the stuff that up for some in
Seattle couldn't do a whole voice day
today techstars they have a voice
incubation tech stars one of the premier
incubations for the startup class world
you guys have heard about these
accelerators Y Combinator tech stars
these are top players they take six
percent I think these days five to eight
percent of the company for the company
to be incubated and started in their
company they give a little money they
get network to get characters to come in
and speak they do things of that nature
a great model for a lot of businesses
over the last decade for me super
exciting
on this one because I've stopped doing
kind of engagement with these incubators
in the startup consumer app world but
this one is specifically focused on
voice and as if you've been following me
at all
I like voice so I'm heading there now
gonna do a fireside chat and then I'm
going to do consulting for eight or nine
or ten of the companies and head back
and then just get a lot of work done and
then head out to Boise Idaho for a
keynote and then head back home and do a
bunch but I'm excited about getting my
hands a little bit dirtier
in in that world I've got something for
the vlog you've been recording right
good so you let me see the transition
there's Patrick Gibbons what's your
official title
of what baby's here so bean are smart
this is actually this may actually have
to be the episode because this is
something that I will not embark on as a
pillar very often and I think Patrick's
story can help so many let me explain I
invested in the company Internet of
Things right your bottle talks to you
I'm running out of water you can use me
for this just where the world's going
right we're here at an incubation around
voice this is not mobile this is not
social this is what I've been in for the
last decade three years ago we started
you know three or four one-man one-woman
divisions in this bigger company Patrick
comes over from another shop I was
really impressed with him kind of hired
him pretty quickly on the spot and it's
it's about his story so vein are smart
Internet of Things is where really where
we started a lot of our work now is in
the voice space not necessarily a direct
line to that but indirectly you know
this term intrapreneur you know being
entrepreneurs within companies
I'm skeptical to it because I'm so
overly romantic about entrepreneurship
it's interesting I think you probably
represent one of the best if not the
single best version in the seven eight
nine year history your history of
vaynermedia Patrick was thrown in there
one-man team no ad I'll finish in a
second one second thank you such a
pleasure while he's introducing Patrick
made its 20th system stayed alive
actually that's so funny you know what
he did he stayed alive until I got good
will guarantee do sir
listen if your idea is stupid like right
if your horse is like you know a horse
son like those machines you put the
quarter in you got to actually run a
race you're gonna lose like you know but
but it's stunning how important the CEO
is how important she and he is it just
it's stunning so how we doing so far
d-roc like we're weekend to the new
start
what do you think some good some bad
something different yeah we're learning
always be learning what about if I ask
the questions right now and you added it
as if I'm not right there right so we're
about to interview Patrick Gibbons who's
the VP of Boehner smart I think he's a
uniquely interesting person for you guys
at YouTube because he won within our
organization and a lot of you work in
organizations and you have
entrepreneurial spirit and you're not
ready to leave so maybe how do you act
like an entrepreneur a K an intrapreneur
inside of an organization I think my
whole approach to it was run as thin and
as hard as I could for as long as
possible and the point of that was to
have low overhead and to be able to do
whatever else on the side I could to
make sure my group was not dragging
things down while we built our
capabilities up so that when the market
was ready we were ready to jump I really
want to continue to inspire you guys to
take the voice space more seriously I
mean I just left here to Seattle for it
right so I'm not I'm not in the business
of like flying places for free just cuz
I think it's strategic so anyway back to
Patrick this interview is to get his
perspectives on how to win within an
organization and the voice space I know
where Gary's heart was and where his
head was in this space I knew he saw the
IOT space being important and growing as
a place where a lot of attention was
gonna move from consumers and where his
client said to be I see so much
opportunity to build new kinds of
interactions here
so we're in like the first half step of
what's gonna be a really long journey
advice and it's cool for me to start
playing already with ways to hack what's
our it's it's still a new system I love
going into meetings with clients right
now or internal teams and being asked
what the best practices are and we
immediately will say look here's a few
things that work in voice here's why
they work but anyone who tells you they
know a best practice is full of [ __ ] at
this point we haven't even been here
long enough no one's tried enough things
and failed at them to prove out the ones
that work so we're super early we're
hacking we're playing in the space and
that's um
fun place to be yeah we're going to they
don't want anything so what's gonna be
no no we can tell everything the whole
thing's gonna have a Russell override or
whatever find somebody who's got a say
song named Patrick Patrick you sign up
for the garyvee wine in month club you
got your email confirmation today just
now you fill um setting up yet but you
will right now right thank you
yeah it makes me happy are you signed up
with your rock you know I know you did
no no but let me give you a good idea
take out your phone right now and go
it's a great idea were you caught up for
a second pill and did you get an email
confirmation now cuz I don't know if
they started do come on is super dacing
can you make it pump because I can see
you weren't planning on yeah I want to
really have fun AJ's gonna have it to be
fun I mean this was super exciting for
me it feels very early social media
reminded me that I can still play in the
tech space and be smart and incredible
founders with clear vision and a
different energy because when you're
selling something that the world hasn't
bought yet you're a different animal but
super easy selling social media and
mobile now selling the future of voices
of infrastructure in our society and how
it interacts is a totally different game
enjoyed it tremendously and I love you
are watching and a lot of you want to be
YouTube stars and a lot of you want to
do what I've done and I always say you
know watch what I do not what I say if
you're just a curious kid go deep into
this void space I I want to use this
moment in my blog to have those moments
eight years from now that makes me so
happy because I get an email from you
that you just sold your company for
seven hundred thirteen million dollars
to Google because you literally watched
this vlog you went out and took the time
and the 40 80 150 hours to learn the
space you got an internship at a startup
you learn something started something
this moment can be the seed of the rest
of your life take advantage of it
take care of man real pleasure looking
forward to jamming together let's take
care of us real good day real good I
wanted to remember it boys
comment of the day on YouTube comes to
you live from Seattle hi Andrew Hayes
Lee says you finally convinced me to get
back into snapchat I don't know what I
haven't watched the episode yet I don't
know exactly what I said but I know
exactly what I said which is there are
practitioners and their headline readers
and as a practitioner of content
creation and distribution snapchat is a
phenomenal place to be a marketer right
now if you care about people under 35 if
you're a stock person and Wall Street
maybe not so much if you're a person
that just lives and needs one thing at a
time maybe not so much but as a
practitioner that wants to run
businesses and get [ __ ] done it's
phenomenal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes